So I started pmsing today,
and I don't know if this is like,
a universal experience. I feel like it is, though.
Um, I've turned into just a feral cat that lives under a porch
that is potentially ready to just murder people.
And I need someone to explain this. Honestly.
It might be Doctor Jolene Brighton.
She's a mutual of mine on here on TikTok,
and she's a genius. But, like,
I remember making fun of the idea of PMS when I was pre kids,
like, early 20s,
and now all of a sudden, I have three kids,
I'm in my, like,
I guess we were. We're calling it late 30s now.
I'm 36, turning 37, um,
and my PMS comes on like a absolutely psychotic episode.
Like Dr. Jekyll, Mr. Hyde,
I am full of rage and sass and attitude and ready to, like,
watch Westeros burn. And I would either like to know if this is like
everybody and this is just how things go
and I need to go to some sort of commune for a couple days,
or do I need to get my hormones checked